I'm going to suggest three different algorithms to you.
These are all examples of supervised classification algorithms and
you should pick one.
Your choices are k nearest neighbors, adaboost and random forest.
You don't know what any of these are right now,
of course, but that's sort of the point.
Here's a tiny bit of information on each one to maybe help you
start making your decision.
If you're brand new to machine learning, you've never done it before, or
it's still kind of a challenge for you to understand the algorithms that
we've talked about so far, I would suggest trying k nearest neighbors.
This is a classic algorithm.
It's very simple and easy to understand, which is a big advantage in
a machine learning algorithm, that you know what's going on.
If you're down with everything we've done so far and
you're ready for a really interesting challenge, I would suggest adaboost or
random forest, which are both examples of what we call ensemble methods.
The name ensemble methods gives you a little bit of a hint of what these two
might be doing.
They're meta classifiers that are built from many, usually, decision trees, so
you have many classifiers and
you sort of have them all working together to come up with a single decision.
It's a little bit like how we choose the president by voting.
There's a single decision of who's the president going to be, and there are many
different people who have different opinions on what that answer should be.
And so what you have to do is you ask the question of many different people and
all together you come up with a single answer.
That's a little bit like what these two algorithms do, but
they do it in slightly different ways.
However, any of the algorithms that you pick should all be
supported in SK-learn so you can rely on SK-learn having something that you can
use straight out of the box.